hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
who are you
Amy castle who I haven't seen in close
to a year she's back in my life
why because I'm woke Little Women
trailer is out that's right you
associate me with Little Women I do I am
short of stature yeah it's a very
misleading title hood have you seen any
of the Little Women movies I feel like
I've seen one when I was really little
like a really little woman and I don't
remember which one yeah I saw that
Winona Ryder one just last night because
I heard this trailer was coming I'm like
I should probably know something about
it you prepped you did your homework
yeah I was an exhilarating experience
that married I do my life the books yeah
it's super feel-good anyway this is the
84th adaptation brought to the big
screen let's watch this trailer grab
your wig I'm excited because of the
director and cast so let's see what they
got this is Meg Amy Betten Joe
I'm working on a novel it is a story of
my life and my sisters make it short and
spicy and if the main character is a
girl
make sure she's married by the end she's
very much what you want too isn't a job
to be famous writer
sounds so crass what she says I intend
to make my own way in the world no one
makes their own way mr. bald woman
you'll need Streep oh she's aunt March
okay can't because it's gorgeous my
dress you made Tony keep still so no one
would see it a lady about humanity
[Music]
Joe is a lost cause absolutely why your
families hope
I believe we have some power over whom
we love it isn't something that just
happens to a person
this production design is crazy we can
leave right now I'll tell stories
showing you here she an actress and you
should have a life on the stage just
because my dreams are different than
yours doesn't mean they're unimportant
[Music]
we have minds and they have souls as
well as just hearts I want to be great
or nothing I want to live in this movie
[Music]
yes
there are some majors to laughing about
[Music]
I'm sold
so who does she marry oh it's so good
yeah it looks great
stellar cast I have some very specific
opinions about yeah looking forward to
this I'm 2 Timothy shall of May to show
wrong in my opinion I mean he looks
pretty damn romantic well it's funny cuz
saoirse ronan that's how you say it
right sure sure yeah Saoirse you just
don't go how it looks like it's gonna be
at work to nagar ronan and timothy
Xiaomei were both a ladybird yes and he
was a pretty big dbag in ladybird this
channel and now he's the one who's
wooing for sorce Rodin's jo in this
movie yes I think it's pretty cool they
get her reunited and he doesn't get a
play such an [ __ ] he's likable anyway
like in any role he true because that
quality even when he's an ass yeah
but this whole cast is just crazy I mean
I think that's part of the beauty of any
little woman adaptation just jam-packed
it with a bunch of awesome female
performers yeah I mean you got Florence
Pugh it here is having just a killer
year Emma Watson I think a lot different
about it so she wrote and of course
Meryl Streep is Anne Marsh
Laura Dern and then they're both in big
lives together that's right they're both
imbue that's right email cinematic
crossover time yes I do have that
thought I've only seen one little woman
adaptation there are so many just keep
them coming
they just keep them coming so you do ask
that question of what's the point of
doing another one I feel like in the
times that we're living in now as a man
I could speak for the woman I'm not
gonna let you talk I'm just sometimes
we're living in now it's important that
women get represented okay okay
understand shush
I'm trying to tell you why you matter
it's important I always saw the 90 for
adaptation okay while it wasn't exactly
you know for me I still appreciated it I
started to grasp like okay I could see
why this story is timeless and important
because the four sisters are very
different personalities
and they all represent a different shade
a lot of women can identify well you can
personality this character with the
importance
independence being able to do what you
want and not just like a lot of the
trailer really capitalizes on woman dark
only designed to be servants to men
right just because yeah yeah exactly but
it's cool that you can take a classic
that has been done so many times and it
just shows the quality of the writing
and of the script and of the characters
that you can keep bringing it back right
I personally like that it's something
that's been done so many times it's a
classic something that is still like
standing the test of time well yeah I
mean you you updated a certain degree
isn't it and I really like how realistic
the interactions feel here yeah sure
it's got that polished production design
but there's something about the
interactions especially when you're
watching like Timothy Xiaomei and sort
of socially Ronin interact with each
other so they're having a real issue
well they have such great chemistry
together on screen and they work
together yeah we know that I think
roediger work is a good fit for this
especially after watching Lady Bird
which we know was a lot of not following
in traditional footsteps of wanting to
do your own thing and be an independent
person yeah so Casarez Joe the main
character just makes sense since that's
a big part of her characters journey I
just want to see a little bit more of
the other characters now I know I want
to see more about mom Watson
Oh Emma Watson especially the dresses
the costume design probably nominated
for something it's like the character of
Beth she's like the musical person in
this story and she's someone who helps
keep the family a little bit she was
like the glue of it and then you got
this actress in here Eliza Scanlon who
I'm not as familiar with her yeah I'm
sure she's done you know some great work
that I just haven't seen yet that's just
the other names are definitely Bob
Odenkirk bob odenkirk isn't this but not
in that's what everyone should be most
excited about it's the male performer
he's not in the Timothy shall of May I
don't care less about it because you got
like a bunch of actresses in here whose
names like you here and most people will
have heard that name before as a
Scanlan's name is not as popular with
Beth is such an important character so
I'm excited to see what scene-stealing
scenes
she hasn't you know and great
opportunity for somebody that is maybe a
little less known than some of the other
characters how cool for her that she
gets you that part of this and what I
find interesting
even though there's been so many
adaptations there was like a modern-day
one that even came out last year that
just flew under the radar jeez I feel
like a lot of people haven't seen Little
Women well I mean I don't remember the
whole thing I'm saying I was like little
when I watch it well it's not exactly
plot a heavy high-concept story
it's a post-civil war 4:30 yeah it's a
slice of life journey of a lot of these
characters over time and it's a
character study of all them literally I
feel like the plot description of it is
women living in post-civil war time yeah
that's pretty much it see how they grow
into adults you know and that's pretty
much the journey of these characters so
excited for meryl streep I'm excited for
her I only saw the 94 version so I
remember at March not being like the
predominant character in it I thought
Marmee was more of a predominant
character but you know I could be wrong
there's one adaptation I saw I haven't
read the book either way next thing I'm
gonna watch all the adaptations and then
I'm gonna read the book come back with a
full movie for not honoring everything I
wanted it to be as a man but you can
still be interested in this you're still
interested it looks great it's great
characters it's great actors and it's
for Christmas it's everything you wanted
- yeah yeah exactly
but probably gonna put big money in so
when all the men are watching cats all
the women who watch alright guys well
are you excited for Little Women thanks
for being here thank you Greg the only
female presence I had was this Wonder
Woman shirt so it's nice to have a real
woman here it helps with clout and
credibility reveal the curtain too much
anyway guys are you excited for this
97th adaptation a little women comment
below you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell follow Amy castle on it's Amy
castle her own YouTube channel dude
soon as you can't follow her on social
media and also I'd like to give a patron
today shout to someone very specific I
normally do like sarcastic patron of the
day shoutouts but I wanted to be sincere
because this is a woman now via Delia
Chamberlain
Adelia has been a longtime patron and
just a friend of ours she's also an
author herself and she has taught me a
lot about the importance of these
movements and such lately but she's been
going through a rather difficult time as
of late she had a pretty big loss
recently so I just want to say I'm sorry
for everything you're going through but
Russ one of the toughest cookies I've
ever gotten to know so happy to know you
and I know that enduring in times of
grief it can be challenging but it also
allows for a growth and like you said
you've been stepping out of your comfort
zone because of it
so just keep doing what you got to do
keep feeling what you got to feel I love
you I adore you and be safe and don't
own pledge it's the most important part
all this still in pledge